[Music]
this feels unpleasantly familiar what
happened last time you don't want to
know
[Music]
[Applause]
everyone can relax this place magproof
make two the trench in cinemas August 4.
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Jonas
we need your help
we're detecting increased aquatic
activity 25 000 feet deep in the trench
it's an ancient ecosystem Untouched by
men whatever is down there is trying to
make its way to the surface
which is a bad idea just a little bit
[Music]
thank you
Jonas
we've got company
it's the biggest night I've ever seen
biggest bag anyone's ever seen
that's the apex predator
everybody back into the station
three massive exit who knows what else
can escape the breach
I just hope it goes better than last
time
what happened last time
you don't want to know
you've seen this before they hunted it
back
we can relax this place is Meg proof
majorness was always afraid of this but
I was also thinking
[Music]
thank you